this is ed here at taker game show and
what we have here is the 15-minute Ace
Combat 7 demo from Bandai Namco's booth
on the show floor now if you're an Ace
Combat fan you'll know that the story is
important and we've got the opening
mission cutscene here so be aware of
spoilers this is also a blind
playthrough and I've got expert controls
switched on if you're not familiar with
Ace Combat that means everything's a bit
more realistic and sim like since you
manually control the roll and your your
aircraft the game also has more arcadey
control scheme for newcomers one thing
to keep an eye out for in this demo is
ace combat sevens new dynamic cloud
mechanics we were told previously that
cloud placement varies each time you
play a mission meaning learning to
improvise and using clouds to your
advantage is a thing you do really
looking forward to playing this one when
it comes out in 2018 and we hope it's a
return to form for the series enjoy
however it lost all its aircraft so it's
sailing empty today the International
Union peacekeeping force reclaims its
bid to the space elevator the port craze
Island air base squadron will rendezvous
with the carrier vulture for a joint
mission the first objective will be to
seize air superiority in Chopin burg in
order to secure a route for the support
squadrons the enemy maintains air
superiority of the chopper so expect
heavy resistance from enemy aircraft
there's more so listen carefully right
from the start of the war the enemy has
been deploying drones
they're using a new advanced type of
drone the unmanned airborne aircraft
carrier the Arsenal bird carries this
new drone NQ 101 the OSI an army headed
at the development of the massive
Arsenal person dispatched them to the
space elevator to provide support
however it's been reported that the
carriers may have fallen into the hands
of the Eurasian Forces if that's true it
could be a significant obstacle for us
we need to regain control of the space
elevator ASAP
good luck out there
[Music]
a squadron SS operation complete
major to begin takeoff sequence
[ __ ] to me
page two specified outraged restrictions
lifted good luck
mage squadron this is the situation for
crazed aerial recon including column are
engaging hostiles you guys will arrive
right in the middle of the action mage
squadron eliminate all bandits in the
current airspace we have the upper hand
but that doesn't
Thank You Bonnie do
H to ban it down excellent work
submitted my part is mine
[Music]
hi target is ready to attack you
why
target was not struck
mr. Washington
macho macho
thanks Julia to me has a lock on you
we're getting random yawn
they to market
three remaining
enemy on your tail
laughs watch out the enemy handle makan
my radar showing abandoned
we just learned that it rooms you get as
utilizing our some vertical never ready
for most bastards are trying to play us
skeleton watch
destroy the arsons bird
[Music]
baby
[ __ ] you
[Music]
target
the entire skeleton
all squadrons PFI
but the enduring trigger
all squadrons be advised command has
ordered a withdrawal all aircraft lead
the operation area immediately dominate
squadron take up the rear deal with
those damn
let the Eternity trigger
[Music]
whether hotshot
you